are we recording in no thank you good
morning
this is tsunami chair of the House Ways
and Means Committee I find that due to
the state of emergency declared by the
governor as a result of the Cova 19
pandemic and in accordance with the
governor's emergency order number 12
pursuant to executive order 20 2004 this
public body is authorized to meet
electronically please note that there's
no physical location to observe and
listen contemporaneously to this meeting
which was authorized pursuant to the
governor's emergency order however in
accordance with the emergency order I am
confirming that we are a providing
public access to the meeting by
telephone with additional access
possibilities by video or other
electronic means utilizing zoom for this
electronic meeting all members of the
committee and select legislative staff
public has access to contemporaneously
listen and if necessary participate in
this meeting by clicking on the
following website address HTTP board
forward zoom us forward J forward nine
one one zero seven one eight eight three
two one or dialing one of the following
phone numbers one nine - nine - oh five
six zero nine nine or one three oh one
seven one five eight five nine to be by
providing public notice of the necessary
information for accessing the meeting we
previously gave notice to the public of
the necessary information for accessing
this meeting including how to access the
meeting using zoom or telephonically
this information is printed in the house
calendar C providing a mechanism for the
public to alert the public body during
the meeting if there are problems with
access if anyone has a problem please
call 603 271 3600 or email HC s @ l EG
state NH that us tooi by joining the
meeting if the public is unable to
access the meeting in the event the
public is unable to access the meeting
the meeting will be adjourned and
rescheduled I want to introduce the
staff that are on the meeting hosting us
Chris Shea the deputy legislative budget
assistance supported by Gen 4 house
community researcher additional staff
members are providing support from the
Legislative Budget Office and House
committee services this is a work
session to gain input from state
agencies and economists and chambers of
commerce about where our revenues are
now and maybe both by the end of this
fiscal year on June 30th and where they
might be
during
y21 the chair will be calling on
predetermined speakers in order in the
morning
an economist Phil Phillips Linton and
the Commissioner and policy team from
the Department of Revenue Administration
in the afternoon we will start with
Tracy Hutchins and Wendy Hutt
respectively executive directors of the
Upper Valley Business Alliance and the
Greater Miramax O'Hagan Valley Chamber
of Commerce we will proceed to
commissioners and staff of the
Department of Insurance lottery and
liquor Commission's and Department of
Safety after that the committee will
review submissions from the judicial
branch administrative services Treasury
securities Health and Human Services
transportation and fish-and-game next
Monday on the 1st we will meet again at
10:00 a.m. in public executive session
to fashion our own revenue estimates
which will be for the first time set as
a series of series of of ranges given
the high degree of uncertainty in the
kovin 19 our copies of the relevant
materials have been posted on the main
page of the General Court website under
the heading remote meetings please note
that if any votes are taken during this
meeting they shall be done by roll call
vote however there should be no
dispositive votes at a work session
let's start the meeting by taking a roll
call attendance when each member states
their presence please also state whether
there's anyone in the room with you
during this meeting which is required by
your right to know well Jim Oh Chris
Chris yes oh so I'm attending from my
home my daughter is here but she will be
leaving people sequentially from
everyone is unmuted now like we
practiced
um so it's representing will
it's ready to do the roll will mute each
person after they've been called it will
representative names present and
Geoffrey alums represent of Carrick I'm
here in Warner by myself at home percent
of Southworth present in Dover alone
blurk is present and alone
representative Schamberg present and
alone representative Tucker present and
alone in Randall's
representative bunker isn't alone at
home in Exeter although my wife may pass
through from time to time as the day
goes on observed Marlo present in
Swansea currently alone but my spouse
representative Stringham I am present in
link in Nana lone representative major
president by myself in Plaistow
representative rice president and Hudson
and I have a husband kids and dogs all
in the room there oh I'm in the I'm in
the dining room they're gonna pass
through frequently so representative all
irate
uh he's muted I see a picture of him but
representative Ami
yeah
is there somebody I'm sorry who's who
was sitting in for represented burns is
their representative Lang is the
permanent replacement for representative
representative de set I'm president loan
and sale
is there a substitute for representative
Edwards no our only substitute is
representative right ace for
representative Burstein I'm here by
myself and beautiful Nottingham New
Hampshire represented all made here by
myself in Lebanon I have a count of 16
present and for no response correct
thank you very much on we will proceed
immediately yes represent all he has his
hand up I don't know if he has a
just a signal that I was still muted
when it reminds me to pay attention to
that we wanted to come
bill Slaton we promised him a half an
hour and we've taken up ten minute
so that with procedure so Philip Sutton
is the economist at the New Hampshire
fiscal policy institute he previously
worked with Legislative Services and the
audit department as I recall and he has
been been studying the New Hampshire
economy I presume for a long time but
particularly since he joined the
Institute four years ago
yes close to four years ago now three
and a half we're looking forward to
hearing what you have to tell us about
where you think things are going in our
economy now in in the near future it's a
little hard to see past that but thank
you very much absolutely thank you very
much to the committee for the
opportunity to speak thank you represent
eval me for the introduction again my
name is Jill Slaton I'm a policy a
senior policy analyst at the New
Hampshire fiscal policy institute which
is an independent nonpartisan nonprofit
policy research organization based in
Concord we focus on a state budget and
revenue policy of some health policy as
well as the state economy which is what
I've been asked to come talk to you
about today so I will share my screen in
terms of questions let's see if I can my
screen sharing is still disabled in
terms of questions I'm happy to take
questions throughout especially if there
are a technical question about a slide
I'll be showing a fair number of graphs
but but I I will leave it to the
discretion of the chair as to exactly
the best way to to move forward on
questions I'll try to I'll try to watch
to see if there are people signaling I
won't be able to share my screen and
have the hand raised feature showing at
the same time I don't believe so I'll do
my best okay I'm going to be able to see
the hands when you whenever you take a
short break if there's a hand I can
transmit it to you but Chris we need to
share the screen looks like I can now
so thank you very much all right now you
should hopefully here we go
you should hopefully be able to see the
slide deck next okay
great excellent so I'll I'll move I'll
move through these but I'll pause again
periodically to see if there are any
questions so one thing that I do want to
note is this is an early overview
because we only have so much information
at this point everything's moving very
fast
you know remarkably fast relative to
what we've seen in Prior economic
contractions in certainly in the
post-world War two ERA there are four
key takeaways I want you to have from
this and this is we'll discuss these in
these slides this is not as sort of the
order that we'll discuss them in and
we're not discussing the details here
but the slides will tie back to these
first that they shock to the economy has
been swift and massive and second the
crisis's impacts are disproportionate
for those with the least ability to
absorb these financial shocks and that
has implications for the broader economy
the last recovery may tell us something
about what is a potential for the next
recovery in terms of recovering from
this economic contraction and it was a
long recovery it was the longest since
we've started sort of recording how long
recoveries are in the United States but
it did leave many people in precarious
financial situations and projections for
future economic growth and economic
activity are very uncertain at this
point but future growth will be
dependent on both public health factors
such as vaccines and the deployment of
vaccines the deployment of treatments as
well as the resources that individuals
and families have to engage in the
economy so keep those points in mind
let's talk a little bit about what we're
seeing in unemployment we have data now
at the state level or what we
traditionally think of as what is the
unemployment rate and that is again
based on that's based on a survey a
survey of households that's conducted
nationally in the twelfth day of each
so the April I pardon me in the week
that includes the twelfth day of each
month so April was the first month where
we saw that impact in New Hampshire and
as you can see on the graph here um
the Great Recession during during leash
in the shaded area here and there was a
pretty substantial and steep increase in
the unemployment rate you can see New
Hampshire is in this green thinner line
and the United States as a whole is in
this thick blue line however that
increase was not nearly as steep as what
we just experienced in terms of the
shock to employment you here we can see
that the national unemployment rate
which again these figures because
they're based on household surveys it's
probably gonna be difficult for them to
settle out for a little while the Bureau
of Labor Statistics actually believes
that they're under counting unemployment
because of the way that people respond
to the questions and the questionnaires
and categorize themselves so in the
automatic categorization so there may be
people who are identified as temporarily
they're out of the labor force or
temporarily not working that we might
think of as more traditionally
unemployed because they aren't able to
work they may have not have been laid
off from their job but they they've lost
that income so the national employment
rate estimated to be about fourteen
point seven percent for April New
Hampshire's is sixteen point three
percent that's preliminary so that's
likely to move around some however it's
unusual for the Hampshire to be higher
than the nation as a whole and New
Hampshire is right now higher than four
of the five other New England states
based on these sort of preliminary
estimates at this point so that's that
may not tell us very much at this point
but that we we do know between the March
in April reports that the estimate is
that 152,000 fewer people were working
in April than in March in New Hampshire
and when you're talking about a labor
force of about 750,000 people then you
know it's a pretty significant amount
and I'll note that the labor force size
itself the people that are engaged in
employment or looking for employment
decreased by about 51,000 people between
March and April based on these data
another way that we can measure
unemployment is through unemployment
insurance claims or claims
for being being receiving unemployment
compensation there are two lines here we
can see the initial unemployment claims
is this line on the bottom that is a
relatively relatively small line on this
in terms of its height on this graph but
the peak was at the previous peak was
about 3,600 people filing for initial
unemployment claims meaning they work on
the unemployment they weren't receiving
an unemployment compensation the week
before in the week following the
recession it apart me in the period
following the last recession that has
spiked to 39,000 in the peak number that
we have here and then it has decline
because these are initial claims they
have declined but the continued claims
you can see a dwarf whatever if the
highest levels that we saw during the
recession which was about 27,000 people
we can see that the continued
unemployment claims many people that
were on from the previous week continues
to climb to levels that aren't seen and
haven't been seen in this dataset and
New Hampshire's unemployment rate that
was on the last data set is also the
highest that that we've seen in that
data sets history for in New Hampshire
specifically I want to I'll show a
little bit more about those initial
unemployment insurance claims to get
into some of the industries you can see
on the left the New Hampshire the
Department of Employment Security has
sort of collected together industry
groups into three categories that they
summarized in their reports now the
foodservice industry retail industries
and the healthcare industries and we can
see in the blue bars from March 15
through May 2nd what was the increase in
initial unemployment claims from that
industry in aggregate and then through
May 9th so adding on another week what's
the initial injury what's the increase
in initial claims and you can see that
foodservice retail and healthcare have
all gone up between these two weeks so
they're continuing to contribute maybe
healthcare is contributing a little bit
faster at this point the the impact may
have been more direct and immediate on
food service and retail and a little bit
more latent on healthcare if we look to
the right then you can see that there's
an increase in each of the sort of
sub-sector industry or by more narrowly
defined industries and we can see that
restaurants are the hardest hit
alongside hospitals doctors and dentists
offices hotels and motels childcare
elementary and secondary schools as well
as bus drivers and higher education
car dealerships beauty salons this shows
the industries that have all seen have
all been the source of at least a
thousand initial unemployment insurance
claims so I'll pause here I want to make
sure I can address any questions about
these before moving on a little bit I
don't see any yet but Phil do you is
there any way to look at the total
unemployment relative to the total total
employment and say January for each of
those for each of those yes so in terms
of where in terms of the traditional
unemployment survey that's a little bit
more difficult to do but at least at
this point it's definitely more
difficult to do I can tell you that
these initial unemployment claims again
this is the March 15th to the weeks
ending March 15th to May 9th so there's
two things about the initial claims that
are important to know one is unlike a
survey it requires actions on the parts
of individuals right they have to apply
for the unemployment compensation and we
don't know if they've subsequently got
the job afterwards right because these
are the initial claims over a period of
time that being said in in this economic
environment there aren't that many
people who are being presumably being
added to to employment in the in
especially in some of these industries
so but that's a caveat for understanding
these conditional unemployment claims in
Prior weeks before March 15th you saw
we're quite low you know we're talking
hundreds hundreds of people would be in
aggregate as opposed to you know we saw
with the week of April 4 39,000 so this
this probably gives us as best as
snapshot as we have now in terms of
where the unemployment has been
occurring since January but I will show
a pie chart showing what employment was
in those sectors in January okay
thank you Arif cinema Brown he has his
should be talking now okay Phil thanks
um I don't see manufacturing on here
which is interesting that it seems like
our manufacturers have been least impact
that it's not a quick statement I don't
know about least impacted but because
they are more you know they are more
likely to fall into the essential
businesses category and and because you
know some of their work maybe may be
easier to do social distancing with some
of their work and some easier to do some
of the physical distancing it could be
that those employers have have been able
to make it a safe environment so but in
terms of where we see the initial
unemployment claims it you know that
given that manufacturing which you'll
see on a subsequent slide is a
relatively significant employment sector
in the economy it is noteworthy that we
haven't seen at least among these these
you know industries as they're laid out
here we haven't seen those initial
unemployment claims coming from there so
I would say yes relative to many of
these industries it's insulated thank
you who is trying to talk at the same
time without raising a hand okay
remain anonymous thank you so go ahead
absolutely so one of the things and
getting to what this committee is going
to be thinking about a little bit more
directly is is we see the impacts on the
restaurant industry in particular but
also accommodations and car rentals in
the meals and rentals tax revenue this
is a graph that many of you have seen
before on the previous slide jects that
I've shared but this shows the April
drop of about 40% in meals and rentals
tax revenue receipts which is again
reflecting merge activity now one thing
that I do want to note is that that
suggests that even that half of March
was affected roughly that suggests that
was about an 80 percent drop in activity
and and that
is in line with the US Bureau of
Economic Analysis reported that
accommodations and restaurant spending
overall and in the u.s. was down sixty
to eighty percent in the last ten days
of March so it's in line with that one
thing I'll note is that the initial the
early numbers oh did we lose the screen
yes okay well I will share it again I
don't know what happened there I just
point out that the current unless
there's a readjustment at the end which
they doesn't ever seem to be meals and
rooms is down fifty nine percent this
month so it's not not anywhere near as
bad as it wasn't beginning yes and that
was where I was about to go when my
screen was interrupted but that he no no
you're quite right it's that that's that
it's looking a little bit better for for
April activity than our sort of worst
fears based on these initial data which
is which is encouraging um
I'll note that you know we talked a
little bit about unemployment thus far
that would directly affect the business
enterprise tax but we can't really parse
through that yet maybe the Department
revenue ministration will be able to and
in the next presentation but it's
difficult to parse through that yet at
this point because it's mixed in with
the business profits tax and then
corporate profits speaking to the
business profits tax may not be tied as
directly to employment may behave a
little bit differently but the overall
economy matters including how much
people do have to spend and that is also
true for the real estate transfer tax
and which has seen a decline thus far in
the early may numbers as far as we know
before the month closes up so there was
a there was a question about what
employment looked like in January from
representing valmy well this graph on
the left the pie chart shows the
estimates for how many employees or what
was employment in each sector in January
and you can see that it's broken out
into the sector's the sort of five
largest sectors that make up more than
half of the employment in the state and
then you get to all the other sectors
which are the other half so you'll note
that in retail trade was the was the
leader for a long time
New Hampshire it's only been recently
passed by health care and social
assistance and then adding an
accommodation and food services those
three sectors make up more than a third
of employment in New Hampshire at least
prior to this remember that the numbers
that we were talking about in terms of
loss of jobs in the food service
industry was you know based on the
initial unemployment numbers near 22,000
or so which is a significant portion of
that 61,000 um and one of the things
that I do want to note as well is if you
look at the graph on the right you'll
see that relative to the average pay for
all employees an average weekly wage for
all employees in calendar year 2018
retail trade and accommodation and food
services are quite a bit lower than what
that statewide average is that you can
see over here and then health care and
social assistance is about where that
average is but there's a lot of
variation within it because remember
this is an average one thing I will note
as well is that durable goods
manufacturing does show up on here to
representative a Brahmans question
durable goods manufacturing is is the
fifth largest sector based on how these
sectors are broken up here but is is not
does not appear to be as impacted at
least based on those initial
unemployment claims so and I see there's
a question ah
Southworth history yes I just wondered
food services of course is quite low am
I on that mean that food services does
not include tips because I know wait
people who make quite good weekly pay
yes so these are reported by the
employer so whether that includes tips
beyond for example if they're if the for
the food service the individual working
food services is making below minimum
wage the employer might you know
depending on the practice might only
verify up to minimum wage um that's a
good question in terms of how these data
are collected and this is but these are
these are relatively complete data which
is one of the because they're based on
some of the same data that are fed into
the unemployment insurance system and so
it is it is not based on a survey
there's a little bit less error here on
that
but in terms of tips I don't know that
there I don't know how they're all
counted here especially beyond the
minimum wage levels that sort of have to
be insured by the employer thank you
okay so one thing that I do want to note
is that you know this is this is a
widespread loss of income and has been
falling as we saw in the prior graphs
I'm disproportionately on those who may
not have had many savings to carry
themselves through at this point it may
not have had much income to serve as a
buffer and so I'll quote a US Federal
Reserve chair Jay Powell who a major
13th noted that among people who were
working in February almost 40% of those
in households making less than $40,000 a
year had lost the job in March based on
research that the US Federal Reserve
Bank at the national level a Board of
Governors had done and you can see on
the graph on the right in New Hampshire
and this is a this is a sort of an
experimental initial survey done by the
US Census Bureau that's called the
household pulse survey and this is
measuring through the week of May 12th
how many respondents specifically in New
Hampshire are able to respond in the
affirmative to some of these questions
and I've highlighted a few here one is
that 45 percent of households in New
Hampshire reported a loss of income
since March 13th
so since essentially the pandemic began
34 percent expect a loss of income in
the next four weeks and again this is
results through the weekend March May
12th and that has an impact on their
ability to pay for goods and services in
the economy 14 percent did not pay rent
or mortgage on time or they have slate
or no confidence that they will pay on
time this month and then 6% identified
that in the last seven days there was
some times they're often not enough to
eat and that's in line you know with
some of the numbers that we've seen in
terms of the constraints on consumer
spending affecting even food security
about one in five households based on
two different surveys about one in five
households nationally
out of food and did not have enough
money to buy more in the last 30 days
and two and five households nationally
which had mothers with children under 12
years old ran out of food and could not
afford more at some point since the
pandemic began now this has implications
for consumer spending and consumer
spending comprises about 70 percent of
gross domestic product in the United
States and consumer spending contracted
between February and March by 7.5% and
the Bureau of Economic Analysis actually
estimates that in the last 10 days in
March consumer spending was down almost
28 percent now again that may be a look
that may be the sort of the lowest point
but you know there are because so many
households that we're seeing or in
responding to these surveys saying
they're having trouble affording food
that's likely leads to larger threats to
consumer spending overall which of
course is a threat to a very large
portion of the economy and of course it
won't disappear all overnight but the
the projections suggest that we'll stay
low for a little bit and we'll talk
about those in a moment now thinking
about the last economic recovery what
what was economic growth you know around
the time of the Great Recession the
2007-2009 Great Recession and since then
here you can see New Hampshire's new
hampshire is the dark blue line here
where the remaining New England states
are the Green Line and the United States
overall is in light blue and you can see
there was this period of time
New Hampshire actually entered the
recession earlier and there was this
period of time where growth was quite
slow in New Hampshire quite sluggish
during the economic recovery um but then
started to pick up a little after you
know between 2014 and 2015 the economy
started to pick up and do quite a bit
better in terms of Gross State product
growth the size of the state economy of
course it's still lagging the US overall
in terms of its growth rate but that's
that's where sort of the positive
picture was now what does that mean in
terms of Owen was there a question I
wanted to make sure that I dressed in a
sexy one
okay great what does what happened to
people's wages during this
time in New Hampshire specifically if we
look at the average of 2004 to 2006 and
compare that to the average of 2017 to
2019 wages by decile and by decile means
basically what percentile are you in in
terms of where the wages are so for
example the 50th percentile is the
median wage in the state the 10th
percentile 10% of wages are lower than
that in the state 90th 10 percent are
higher and so we can see here the change
over this time across this from the
prior to the last recession across the
economic recovery we saw that lower
wages and median wages didn't grow very
much and either about flat over this
time period and that has implications
for what the what the economic recovery
looks like indeed if we look at if we
break it out year by year these are the
same data although slimmed down so just
we have the 10 to 20 50th 80th and 90th
percentiles so think about green is
lower income and the median 50th
percentile is an orange and the blue are
the higher income household we can see
that there's a was a decline in sort of
real purchasing power inflation adjusted
purchasing power from around the time of
the recession to about 2015 and only
when that economic growth started
picking up did we see that the wages
rise on the lower level and that has a
positive feedback loop that helps the
economy because then more consumers have
more a larger ability to spend now I saw
that there was a hand raised as well and
I want to address yes
all right so Valerie Valerie yeah I'm
trying to figure this mutant unmute
thing thank you
Phil yeah mr. Slaton you spoke earlier
about the comparison to the the
recession back here in two thousand
seven eight nine cetera and trying to
compare that to recovery from this the
two different lists apples and oranges
there they may both be recovery but
they're certainly not
similar yes wait and I don't sorry go
ahead
well the question on that is if we have
a v-shaped recovery versus a u-shaped
recovery how is that going you know for
lack of better terminology how would
that affect New Hampshire which because
of our broad tax base tends to be more
rapid in every circumstance yeah so I
think that it certainly the v-shape
versus a u-shaped recovery question is
is a certainly one that's paramount when
you're thinking about this because there
have been a lot of supports put in place
to try to promote that v-shaped recovery
and I'll talk about some of the
projections a little bit you know on a
subsequent slide but that if if we are
able to sort of maintain connections
between employers and employees if we're
able to maintain income supports for
individuals and families a lot of the
policies that we've seen particularly at
the federal level but also at the state
level have been targeted at doing that
sort of getting through this relief
period so that the recovery is faster I
think that you know that's that's a
scenario that we're looking for right
that's what we are aiming to be able to
do right is to prove to support that
v-shaped recovery so that were able to
snap back into that position if we look
at the last recession there's I think
that presents risks right even in New
Hampshire that we are talking about a
longer slower recovery and it really
does depend I mean one of the key things
here is the public health factor yeah
does Public Health permit us to do the
public health concerns permit us to be
able to you know go you know move
quickly back to a growing economy if
there's a vaccine tomorrow when we're
able to get you know a million vaccine
doses deployed into New Hampshire in you
know in a short period of time then
great I think that v-shape recovery is
much more likely I think that there's
going to be activities that are normal
economic activities that's not to say
they wouldn't be replaced by something
new but there are normal economic
activities that will slow growth and
curtail parts of
the economy and I don't know that we'll
be able to replace those with other
activities fast enough to really get us
to that v-shape but if we but certainly
the policies that have been put in place
are aimed at supporting the ability for
the economy to get to that v-shape and I
hope I dressed your question and I see
you have another raise your hand again
so and yes no yep it's system and I have
thank you for that the uu race two
issues on there which are a little
concerning to me one you're talking
about I quote healthy or perfect
environment when it's never going to
happen because you know walking down the
street is actually more dangerous than
catching colvin but particularly with
the speed people are driving these days
but the question is we have a high debt
now that is being incurred that's going
to stifle any recovery that may take
place and while it may be a short-term
stimulus it's gonna be a long-term drag
on the economy will you be addressing
that so in this presentation I am
wouldn't they all know is that when we
get to the Congressional Budget Office
projections they do incorporate the
effects of recent federal policies on
the on economic growth one of the one of
the interesting things about the
environment that we're in is that we
have a very low interest rate right now
at the federal level I'm assuming you're
talking about federal debt and federal
public debt we have a very low interest
rate right now at the federal level it
makes them it makes money relatively
cheap to borrow if you will and that
that is something that you know for for
better or for worse we're in a situation
where we sort of have to take advantage
of that to be able to make that v-shaped
recovery or even a u-shaped recovery as
possible as it can be given the
circumstances that were in but you know
in certainly the long-term debt
considerations that we have that has a
potential economic impact down the road
it's unclear there's not a lot of
evidence to suggest that it's going to
be a near-term or medium-term economic
impact but long-term there's certainly
you know certainly reason to be thinking
about how how the deficits especially
and the long-term debt can be brought
closer into balance but that is a that
is a much longer-term consideration than
the time horizon that we're talking
about here based on based on the
evidence that we have around how that
long-term that affects economic growth
you know in in the immediate recovery
period and I hope that answered your
question
Thank You Phil we're gonna have to go
faster yes if there's going to be enough
time to talk with dr8 they've got an
awful lot of material yes absolutely so
so going through these just a reminder
that you know we saw a dip in real
purchasing power for a while and that
probably means that even in folks low
and even to a certain extent
middle-income folks probably didn't
weren't able to save as much and we're
able to retain their savings during this
during this time period and we see that
in other data to here's median household
income for example from 2005 to 2018
with the inflation adjustment and Orange
and the scale adjusted so you can see
the changes there was a long period
where a median household income wasn't
back to pre-recession levels until again
we see this 2014 to 2015 period and
there was a reminder we were talking
about median household income we're
talking about the middle of a
distribution so this is the distribution
in New Hampshire as of 2018 we can see
that roughly more than more than one out
of four households in New Hampshire for
bringing home $35,000 a year or less so
given the giving cost of living that has
implications for their you know for
their ability to again continue to
engage in the economy and potentially
have savings that permit them to engage
in their conduct details so and was
there a question about that slide it
looks like it's sorry it looks like it
was
one out of four four seven seven yeah so
it's almost it's more than whatever yeah
and the reason I say more than one out
of five is because if you account for
the margins of error and go to the
extremes in each category then you're
still you're still just a little bit
over twenty percent so sorry but it's a
band it's about one in three that are
$50,000 or less as well so um so many
households you know to sum up quickly
here many households had few resources
leading into this crisis and again that
has impacts for what the what the
economy looks like immediately
afterwards and how that interacts with
what people are able to spend in the
economy immediately afterwards
almost half of households in new renter
households in New Hampshire were paying
30% or more of their annual incomes in
rent last year about $100,000 lived in
poverty and a survey of US adults so not
just New Hampshire but throughout the
United States found that of about four
and ten US adults a little under that
when faced with a hypothetical of
expense of four hundred dollars said
they would not be able to cover it or
they would not cover it using cash
savings or a credit card they would pay
off at the end of the month they'd have
to borrow money from someone sell an
asset or they just wouldn't be able to
pay it for twelve percent of them so
that's it's a high number of people who
have a relatively low amount of savings
it's probably a lower number in New
Hampshire but it's still you know
definitely a nonzero number in terms of
people who don't have very many savings
going into this crisis
so now projections looking forward this
is a graph showing the Congressional
Budget Office projections and these are
updated some of you have seen a similar
graph before these are may 19th
projections so they've been updated
recently you can see historically the
blue bars show the annualized change in
gross and real gross domestic product
and raise inflation adjusted gross
domestic product here's the Great
Recession you can see the rise in the
unemployment rate which is this orange
line here and when we get to the current
period and the projections you can see a
massive drop in the Congressional Budget
Office's projections for
the quarter that we're currently in
quarter two of 2020 now again this is
annualized so if this pace were to
continue throughout the year what is
what would that do to the economy but
it's a thirty seven point seven percent
contraction on an annualized basis is
what they're projecting now for the
senton for this quarter now it does come
back there's growth returning for the
rest of the year
the CBO does assume that the distancing
measures that we've put in place for
public health reasons would be relaxed
over time and people would engage with
each other more in sort of a more
gradual fashion but it does not you know
in under this modelling it does not
suggest that v-shape recovery in terms
of snapping back to immediately where we
were before this crisis hit you know the
unemployment rate is projected to be and
these new numbers are out 8.6 percent in
the last quarter of 2021 consumer
spending will still be lower and the
economy will still be slightly smaller
in that last quarter of 2021 again based
on these projections one thing I do want
to note about these projections is that
there's a large amount of uncertainty
and because this is a crisis unlike any
other economic crisis that we've seen in
the modern era it's not to say that
economists can't model it well but it's
very difficult to project and the
economic indicators that we rely on such
as unemployment may be unreliable for
some time because of the Swift changes
and public health concerns are again
paramount when thinking about what's
going to happen to economic activity um
the persistence of unemployment is the
key key unknown how well government
responses are it's supporting people and
making sure that people have incomes and
businesses stay intact so that there's
businesses for people to spend money at
and so there's customers for those
businesses um you know the government
responses and the health of the
financial system especially after some
of those responses have been have been
curtailed as are important variables and
again the ability of the economy to
bounce back depends on whether people
have money which is why I've spent a
fair bit of time talking about where the
last recession over the last recovery
sort of left us and what portions of
what portions of the economy are or what
portions of the population have only
certain amounts of resources because you
know it's important for understanding
our ability to sort of you know to
bounce back and to recover quickly from
this so again your fork the four key
takeaways and I hope we've addressed all
of these is the shock to the economy has
been Swift
the crisis has been disproportionate on
for those who have the least ability to
absorb the financial impacts and that
has implications for the coming recovery
the last recovery left a lot of people
in a situation where it's not not
necessarily easy for them to withstand
this this impact and projections for
future economic growth are are uncertain
they suggest however it's going to be a
little bit slower than that v-shaped
recovery that we're all hoping for um
because of future growth being dependent
on both public health and I'll add in
the resources that individuals and
families have available to engage in the
economy so with that I'm happy to take
any questions given the the time with
the chair alots and I also want to hear
from the Department of Revenue
administration to I'm very interested in
what they have to say okay we have
represent of Schamberg asking a question
yes ma'am thank you madam chair can you
hear me yeah
fill in the material that the follow-up
material you sent to chairman all me in
the abstract by Jason Furman of Harvard
under the portions title background on
cyclical pressures on state budgets it
mentions that a 1% point increase in
unemployment rate that there is an
increase has been associated with a 3.7
percent reduction in state tax revenues
per capita are you able to determine
maybe from the New Hampshire
unemployment figures available to you an
estimate in the dollar amount on new
hampshire revenue impact per capita yeah
so per capita I can't say and that that
formula as well and it's an excellent
question that formula as well is based
on sort of the national aggregate what's
you know what's the what are state
revenues at across the nation right
including California including Texas
including Florida and that comparing
that
the national unemployment rate so if you
know you wouldn't want to use the New
Hampshire unemployment rate you could
use the national unemployment rate if
you did that and you know your again
assuming that New Hampshire's New
Hampshire's revenue system responds in
the same way to unemployment as the
national as the state's revenue systems
in aggregate around the country respond
and that's that's probably not the case
so - and to you know sort of to provide
an example of that I performed that
calculation you know if the national
unemployment rate has changed this much
in a rough way what does that do to our
general and education trust fund tax
revenue just tax revenue and it suggests
that in New Hampshire that in fiscal
2021 we'd see a roughly 700 million
dollar impact I think that's too high I
don't think it's going to be that big of
an impact in fiscal 2021 so I would
really defer to what what you're about
to hear for the rest of the day in terms
of from the state agencies because
they're going to have a more sort of
precise idea tailored to our revenue
system exactly you know as to what that
looks like
however I think that national modeling
that we saw from the Center on Budget
and Policy Priorities based on what the
shortfalls that are projected would be
based on that sort of national formula
just looking at the nation's tax dollars
tax revenue dollars an aggregate as a
whole I think that's still informative
for the committee to be able to
understand the potential magnitude of
this relative to what we saw in the
Great Recession of 2007 to 2009 and what
we saw in the early 2000s the 2001
recession I think it's still important
context but but I wouldn't be able I
wouldn't recommend sort of applying that
formula directly because of the the way
that formula was produced to understand
the national picture I hope that answers
your question
looks like it thank you
you agree that there are two general on
differences between New Hampshire and
other states and in general if you're
just looking at it
one of them is our mix of industries and
size of industries and the other one is
our tech system Texas in very different
ways than most states do yeah so I would
definitely agree on the second point in
the first point I think that the mix of
industries in terms of this crisis in
the immediate effect I would say that
our mix of industries does put us sort
of it just a little bit of a
disadvantage in terms of in terms of the
you know leisure and hospitality
accommodation food services those
industries retail being important
sectors here that being said you know in
terms of employments the mix of
industries isn't dramatically different
from a lot of other states but in terms
of income generated you know there there
are likely some differences there that
that do affect new hampshire but
certainly the the tax revenue system
point when we're comparing to other
states and looking at other states
forecasts and other states have been
forecasting revenue or many other states
have made an attempt to forecast revenue
it is important to remember that we we
collect tax revenue in different ways
here than in most other states in the
country thank you
I don't see any other hands up so thank
you very much for presenting to us and I
hope you'll find dra is interesting as
you are thank you thank you very much
for the committee's time I really
appreciate it I want to call next on
we've got I think for people from DRA in
India attendees and I'd like Chris Shea
to unmute them perhaps Commissioner step
will will introduce everybody so that
you're reminded to unmute if we have if
you have to be thank you
so represent of all me we have
Commissioner step
ron's and devin roderick are all unmuted
to speak to you thank you good morning
madam chair members of the committee can
you hear me yes okay good Lindsay's deaf
Commissioner from the Department of
Revenue and as Chris mentioned I have
Melissa Rollins senior financial analyst
and devin roderick financial analyst
with me as well and i guess this is a
question for Chris did you want us to
have video as well and be able to share
our screens or were you going to share
our presentation or did we want to just
walk through it it's really up to the
we'd like to see the presentation on the
screen I'm not sure so I can either put
it up or we could allow for Lindsey or
one of her staff to control it I would
like do you want to control it
yourselfer yeah I think it would be
helpful if Melissa Rollins could put
that up because she and I are alternate
back and forth so that you don't have to
hear just one of us the whole time
okay good so I think Melissa should have
some ability to do that now it'll just
take a moment we have to change the
roles of I'm making Melissa a co-host
now also at least on my screen everybody
is showing up at the bottom on the right
I don't know if we can do anything about
moving whoever is speaking there you are
so so I think is able to share her
screen now mm-hmm
yep
are you able to share your screen yeah
there we go see sort of let me just get
here have the right right top side of a
page on meals and rental stacks on my
okay but we can see it and then make it
fullscreen right now it's better
good yes okay so good morning thank you
for having us today as I mentioned I'll
do a little introduction and then
Melissa and I'll kind of alternate the
tax type so what we've prepared is
revenue estimates for fiscal year 20 and
also for fiscal year 21 for the larger
tax types that the Department of Revenue
administers the updates that we made two
estimates were done by adjusting fiscal
year 2020 plan based on currently
available data either through April or
May depending on the tax type obviously
May is not complete yet but for some
taxes the majority of the revenue comes
in before the end of the month so we
tried our best to work off of the most
recently available information we
updated the estimates based on the
expectation and result of revenue prior
to Co vid so revenues kind of through
February as well as the expected revenue
impact digging into effect the kovat
pandemic and we did that on a monthly
basis both for fiscal year twenty and
for fiscal year 21 and we'll show that
for each of the tax types consideration
was also given to the different payment
types the tax periods that are paid in
any given month and how those
payments may be affected before during
or after the current stay at home
restrictions that were operating under
lastly full disclosure obviously these
estimates are subject to change revenues
coming in and more information is
available on a daily basis
I'll just also mention to start
obviously these are unprecedented times
we're in uncharted territory
we don't have anything really to go off
of in terms of historic impacts are the
historic results so we've done our best
to kind of aggregate a lot of
information that's available publicly
also take into account obviously what
we're seeing in revenue and kind of
dissect everything and do our best to
provide an estimate of where we think
think things are going so I'll have
Melissa flip to the second page and
we'll get started though starting with
the meals and rentals tax the historical
breakdown of this tax is 80 percent
meals 17% from rooms and three percent
for motor vehicles and that's important
because we've actually made adjustments
to revenue based on that breakdown
because the impact to meals may be
different than the impact to rooms and
so that's the breakdown that we're
operating under we adjusted revenues
compared to plan by just under 1% to
start even prior to the COBIT pandemic
it looks like M&R was going to come in
about 1% under plan so we made that
adjustment to start and then as I
mentioned the M&R components we
considered them separately in every
month and we adjusted based on different
scenarios so for example in April the
April actual month-over-month change was
a reduction of 37 percent in meals 54
percent in hotel or rooms and 21 percent
in motor vehicles and now obviously
April revenue is for March activity and
we know March was when we started to see
the impacts of kovat the month of March
started out fairly normal and very
quickly turned to not be so normal
anymore
so that's the initial impact that we saw
and then moving into May obviously the
month is it closed but based on what
we've seen to date we anticipate that
the change from March will be fifty four
percent reduction in meals 88 percent
reduction in hotels or room rentals and
75 percent reduction in motor vehicles
and again this is May revenue which is
based on April activity in April is
really the height of the impact from
kovat so that we're kind of viewing as
our low point now that we're into May
which the revenue will be reported in
June we're starting to see some
restrictions lifted so hopefully the
revenues will start to trend back up and
so it's we're anticipating that May is
kind of the low point of the revenues in
terms of M&R we actually could I just
interject for a minute and when you do
the adjustment in each of these you
talked said at one point you were doing
it through February but in another point
it looked like it was was through the
March data or the April data right so
sorry I'll back up for just a second we
first made an adjustment to what we
thought 2020 actual was going to be
without the impact from coal bed prior
to kovat so through February activity
that was reported in March it looked
like M&R was going to underperform
regardless of kovat by about 1% as
compared to plan but we first made that
adjustment to kind of true up where we
thought plan was going to come in then
for May and June as melissa is showing
on the next screen in May and June we
did the actual impacts from Ovid because
all of our investments are based on
impact from plan and so we wanted to
make sure we were starting with an
accurate plan number thank you you're
welcome
so excuse me so for the other taxes that
are not that are reported
the same month those or on those are
through February to make the adjustment
yes the adjustment to plan yes we would
so one thing then I'll note before we
look at the specific months is fiscal
year to date were 8.6 percent below plan
and we are 3.6 below
percent below prior year obviously the
impacts of COBIT include the selling of
meals the renting of rooms motor vehicle
rental and then low increased
unemployment rates and reduced consumer
confidence resulting in people having
less disposable income or ability or
desire to kind of eat out we notice
though based on the preliminary May
filings that the revenue will actually
be better than we initially expected and
that's due to the performance of chain
restaurants and fast food we had
adjusted the entire meals category
downward initially based on the impacts
of restaurants and then what we've seen
as may revenue has come in is that there
are some subcategories like I mentioned
like fast food that are doing better
than a regular brick-and-mortar table
service restaurant so we did make some
adjustments there onto the next slide
the chart at the top you will see
estimated revenue adjustments by month
and this is where we do the monthly
adjustment to plan you'll see the
reduction of 61 percent in May is our
low point with reductions decreasing
moving through fiscal year 21 where we
anticipate that we will get very close
to plan by the end of fiscal year 21 the
second chart in the middle of the page
is just showing April actual and then
May and June estimates compared to the
original plan
our revised plan and then what that
difference looks like and then the
bottom chart is just the summary of we
anticipate our reduction compared to
plan of forty six point nine million for
fiscal year twenty and sixty three point
seven million in fiscal year twenty one
for M&R these charts you'll see for
every tax type so we'll kind of repeat
this same analysis so I can answer any
questions on these at this point yes
well we have a question from them
surnames yeah I'm just wondering on the
fiscal year twenty one you've got a
month by month there's a set of
percentages against plan and what aware
of the plan numbered can we see the plan
number is because I don't think we've
got a plan for fiscal year twenty one
its month by month right so at this
point there isn't an official playing
produced by das that gets produced in
July
however we sort of did a mock plan on
our end so we could adjust these month
by month because we knew there would be
a gradual change and a gradual increase
so that's what those those adjustments
are and adjustments to the revenue so we
could end up with a final number for
fiscal year twenty one have a mock have
the mock plan numbers yes if you could
just give those to us for the entire
presentation later that would be good
listen up so what's your assumption
about about restaurants being fully
opened but you know ensure inside
service you must have made some
assumption to that
our general assumption is that the
stay-at-home order starts to be lifted
in a greater effort at the beginning of
June and based on how we receive the
information we have it by category of
restaurant but we don't necessarily know
if there's only indoor dining or indoor
and outdoor dining so we had to just
kind of make a general assumption and
what we're looking at is basically a 25%
improvement month over month to get that
gradual slope back to normal obviously
if things happen sooner and restaurants
are fully open by the middle of June
then that might change this trajectory
or if things stay locked down longer
that might change it as well but this
kind of like I said assumes a June first
a little bit of relaxation and then a
25% increase going back though so my
sense is that those states for this to
that once they indoor restaurants open I
think people will come back very quickly
but when it comes to rooms I think
they'll come back but not as fast as
dead yeah I agree that is probably what
we will likely to see and that is one of
the reasons why we kind of looked at
each of those categories meals rooms and
motor vehicle rentals separately because
obviously motor vehicle rentals we need
people to be traveling by air again in
order to be showing up at the airport
and looking to rent a car and so we did
look at each of those individually and
adjust them accordingly one other thing
I will mention about M&R because we've
been getting a lot of questions about
this is whether or not the reduction in
M&R revenues will impact the amounts
that are distributed to the cities and
towns each year and and I did a
preliminary analysis and the short
answer is we do not anticipate
impact for fiscal year 22 what's
distributed to the cities and towns
because the total amount that is
distributed has been capped for a number
of years and that's done in the budget
bill in HB 2 here and we are currently
capped at a distribution of sixty eight
point eight million and even with this
reduction in revenue the formula would
still produce an amount in excess of
that cap so we will trigger the cap
again this year so you're suggesting we
might not trigger it in 21 in 21 based
on these initial estimates I believe we
will trigger it again but most of the
conversation to date has been with the
municipalities about the money that they
received that's good news for them yeah
we've got to pay the full amount to the
school districts correct correct in the
counties so in the in 21 you're assuming
that by the by the fall of 21 that will
beginning back to nearly what the plan
was for meals and rooms correct
correct again this assumes that on June
perks including hotels cars yep that we
that the things we'll be returning
towards normal obviously time will tell
and there's a lot of speculation about
what will happen but we did need to make
an assumption about how the economy will
be reopened and so that has been our
operating assumption at this point right
so major has a question thank you madam
chairman Lindsay have you done an
analysis based upon a second wave
possibly
burnings let us say second wave starts
in September we have not anticipated a
second wave in this analysis but since
we know now the impact on revenues in
May which may was like I said April
activity and that was really kind of a
full lockdown and we will know the
impact once we have June revenues of
what the month of May looked like as
things were relaxed now that we have
those data points we can forecast or
model what a resurgence would look like
or additional lock downs would look like
in the future because we'll have the
data to know what the restrictions do to
impact revenue so you've done that we
haven't specifically done it but we have
the data to do that if that's something
if there's specific scenarios that you
would like us to run in terms of a
resurgence that is something that we
could do biggest there right now is
whether or not this might be a second
wave second wave could happen as a
result of the way that we're opening
things now
and we don't know should be prepared
yeah estimates if there is a second wave
so sure right so you also don't know
whether we're going to be better
prepared for a second wave in terms of
how we handle it and handle it
differently than we handled it before
and you haven't got the June data we're
talking about it yet so right so if that
is a good point when we once we have May
information which is really like I said
a worst-case scenario and then once we
have June that is a slightly improved
and the Mott the stay-at-home 2.0 the
modified order we can then use those two
data points to say if we have a
resurgence in the fall and we lock down
fully for a month or fully
two months or if we partially restrict
for a couple months we have the data now
to know what that would look like thank
you we've got oh we've got three hands
now
rapture sounds worse thank you see that
I'm unmuted
I appreciate representative of Brahmas
optimism but I'm very concerned about
the restaurants I know some people have
less money some restaurants are not
going to reopen and people in the
at-risk group whether we say they're
over 70 whatever should not be eating in
crowded restaurants at all so you know I
sort of like the approach you took but
it's hard for me to say any we'll see
anyway restaurants can bounce back
quickly I have a 90 year old mother our
whole family's being told not to eat in
restaurants at this time sure so I think
like I said our operating assumption
here was a 25% kind of improvement
month-over-month which hopefully kind of
strikes a balance between those that do
want to get back into restaurants versus
those that will be remain out of
restaurants for a variety of reasons
also something else to consider as well
as it's probably some period of time
before restaurants are back to full
capacity even if they're able to have
indoor dining it's likely that at least
to start they'll need to operate at a
reduced capacity so again this analysis
kind of takes all of that into
consideration with that periodic
increase in the month-over-month
reduction in revenue thank you very soon
if a meme says a question again yeah
again sorry yeah I just wanted to second
if you will
representative majors question about a
resurgence and suggestion that it would
be helpful to us and more broadly to try
to reject out revenues
with the assumption of a resurgence to
use the word that was used a
re-emergence of the of the virus sure
and that's I'd like to see that if we
could sure I think what would be helpful
to us and if there are specific
scenarios you'd like to see you know I
don't want to say I'm not a public
health expert I don't want to say when
the resurgence will happen but if you
wanted to give us some scenarios we can
certainly run those through so if you
wanted to see a resurgence with a
partial lockdown starting in December or
November we can definitely do that
but I think it would be helpful to us if
we had the parameters around when that
would happen just so that we're not the
ones I'm saying when when and if a
resurgence would occur I don't know how
we do this but it seems to me that it
would be reasonable to for the second
number to assume the projectory that you
have up to November and then then go
back to the situation and was it May and
come back down with a similar slope sure
that's something that we can do and that
would give us a highest loss possibility
I think if we do that sure
I'm representing with Brahmi yeah quick
we get the revenue report just today
from Chris it looks like we're 15 point
4 million down and wasn't room so you
don't exist you'd normally don't get it
was the last two days do we correct and
representing nature thank you
yeah I would like to see a another one
based upon September and the reason why
is that
we're experimenting now we're opening up
and then especially throughout the
summer that's where people want to get
yeah the horses so things something's
going to happen within two weeks after
this so look at September starting see
that or we can do both a September
resurgence and a November resurgence and
if possible it may be helpful to wait to
the middle of June so that we have June
revenue to give us the start of that
trajectory back up I think this may be
its it'll be even more hypotheticals and
then feasible if if we tried to do these
before we've got the June revenue right
but I'm afraid of a triple double
resurgence one one in August or
September which would probably be
smaller but then another one flu hits
that the health people are worried about
most
so I think we've run out of questioners
okay well we can move on to tobacco tax
then all right tobacco tax this will be
the same layout that Lindsay just went
through for M&R a little bit less to
talk about with tobacco tax one one
thing that we did find interesting is
that we saw a spike in March there was a
50% increase in stamp sales are
essentially stocking up for kovin 19 and
with the stocking up in March we once we
saw that was anticipated we kept a close
April and May April we did see an
increase which we had expected because
if you remember tobacco stamps they're
typically bought on the payment comes in
the next month so April was a good month
compared to plan it was about 35% ahead
of plan and then we made an adjustment
for me because as males come in we've
been noticing and this is sort of what
we anticipated that these stocking up
are these extra purchases and purchasing
of stem cells that occurred we're not
all used up so again the industry saw
this covin 19 coming they scooped up a
bunch of a bunch of stamps in March and
anticipation of some lock down they went
through those stamps in April and then
now we haven't seen as much stamp
purchase and will end up being down
slightly we adjusted it down slightly 5%
but then we anticipate that analyzing in
June and if you see on the second on the
chart their estimated revenue
adjustments by month we didn't make any
adjustment to tobacco for fiscal year 21
partly in evidence that we've read in
newspapers there's some interests that
have been out there expecting the
cigarettes will perform well stressful
environment
there hasn't been any signs of people
decreasing usage above normal and there
wasn't anything pleading to us that
there would be a loss further than that
we had already anticipated for fiscal
year 21 so we didn't make any
adjustments to to fiscal year 21 you
have been keeping an eye on it we have
looked at these cigarettes to see if
there's anything that has increased
their cigarettes having they haven't
taken in a huge market of course we're
just getting ramped up with that still
but they're not they're not excelling at
a fast rate that we would think there
would be any increase there are they
decreasing at a rate that we feel like
they would adjust revenues so for fiscal
year to date or 2.9 percent ahead of
plan for tobacco and compared to prior
year were four percent ahead of plan
again you can see that looking at April
we were ahead may we predicted the 5%
decrease June we predict the where plan
was for difference from April to June of
an increase of 9% you just see that I
think a question came in from
representative Stringham oh yes sure
that just the question I had is a lot of
the national figures say that a lot of
Lauterbach tobacco Stickles go to
out-of-state people you know it was it
was being considered that with fewer
travelers to new hampshire because of
the virus we may have fewer tobacco
sales is is there any indication of why
that was that assumption is incorrect or
do you have any comment on that one way
or the other or more the sales going in
state if you know or is you know is
breath perhaps the national reputation
of us being an exporter of tobacco
unfounded
thanks actually the figures we don't
keep track of the house stamps are sold
whether they're sold in state or out of
state anecdotally I think we are keeping
an eye on as closely I think you'll
remember we had spoken about it several
months ago June 1st Massachusetts put a
flavor band
they're tobacco cigarettes Mahnomen film
in which every cigarettes and loose
tobacco and we might see a buck from
that to your point representative string
them depending on how cross-border sales
if people are not coming over the border
to to purchase those and may not be a
big spike and we're sort of keeping an
eye on that at this point I don't think
we have anything showing us any signs
showing us that we're seeing a decrease
based on cross-border sales
I think the decrease really in May is
based on that stocking up of stocking up
of stamps in March I think June will be
more telling in that area yes we have a
situation where a lot of the large
tobacco stores are in our border on the
southern border and on the western
border we have a big store tucked away
in Lebanon that sells that and beer to
the Vermonters and despite the Vermont
but said that people who were working
could not come across the border to work
but people who were buying could come to
New Hampshire I haven't figured that one
out yet and I know that a lot of
Massachusetts people have been coming to
New Hampshire still despite the stay at
home owners do you have any way to
separate out the traditional cigarettes
from from the other tobacco products
after those are reported separately so
cigarettes are reported based on stamp
sales and other tobacco products OTP
which is least tobacco pipe tobacco
cigarettes those are reported on on a
separate separate return yes
is that it returns of the tobacco
settlement how many cigarettes were
selling is going to be important to next
year's tobacco settlement money and I
was wondering if you could give us the
breakdown for your estimate for what
cigarettes alone would be yeah I think
and this is just going off the top of my
head the bulk of the bulk of the sales
have been I think it's about ninety six
percent is cigarettes and four percent
is other tobacco products the other
tobacco products has been gaming gaming
some speed over the last few years but
but not enough I believe it used to be
like two percent then we got three
percent then it's up to a person I'm
sure we'll continue to increase would
the taxing on e-cigarettes because that
falls under the OTP category but there's
still obviously the the bulk of the
sales are our cigarettes and then
represent our string and I just also
wanted to note that I believe it was in
revenue I mean the Republican caucus
where you had the Chamber of Commerce
and the chain of Commerce women on in
the Hampton area did say and this was a
few weeks back that traffic was still
pretty heavy and was mining the
boulevard of Hampton Beach for with
Massachusetts plates so if that's any
indication of people still coming up we
might be able to use that that evidence
a little bit that people are still
crossing the borders and the sale and
the Chamber of Commerce person was quite
eloquent about that being a mainstay of
their economy there as well as a source
of code in the area when when they came
to our caucus so our episode of a
brownie has a question but I would just
climb my major two weekends ago and
laughter cause with Massachusetts yeah
that's not what not my question so
that's why make sure we had the vaping
hearings we had we heard from
convenience stores that menthol
cigarettes will be banned in mass is
that what you were talking about yes
and they anticipated that they'd be will
increase in sales here so when you when
you did your estimates going forward
back to work center items point about
maybe there would be some I would
anticipate a little bit of a loss of
sales to cross border but I think that's
gonna be offset my sense it will be
offset by the menthol cigarette sales is
that safe to say I think it's fair at
this point I believe it's June first
that that menthol being goes into effect
from Massachusetts so we'll we'll see
that coming up here shortly
but I think that's a fair that's a fair
statement that they could offset each
like I said in March we saw some
stocking up on stamps and who knows if
in Massachusetts they're doing the same
thing at this point so we may not see
that revenue right away right away if
they are stocking up before those
products are no longer on the shelves or
if there's any black market activity
that goes on at that point another thing
that we don't know is how many of the
people that that would consider coming
to New Hampshire have already been
coming to New Hampshire that's that's
there okay okay I don't see any further
questions on this one so maybe we can go
on to the interested in the dense tax
okay so with the interest in dividends
tax I'll try to go through this slowly
we took a lot of things into account
when coming up with these additional
revenue estimates so just to start
because we often
talk about this we wanted to put these
numbers up front the breakdown for the
interest in dividends tags 41% for tax
year 17 was dividend income 35% were
distributions 15% was interest income
and then 9% was federally tax-exempt
interest income so I know when we talk
about interest in dividends interest
being the first word I think that's
often where our mind goes but when you
look at the breakdown from the tax
interest income is really only 15% with
dividends and distributions on being the
vast majority so just putting that out
there to start
so the first adjustment that we made was
we reduced the fiscal year 20 plan by 4%
and that's what I was talking to earlier
about where we felt fiscal year 20 with
land without koban so it was kind of a
right sizing of the plan so first we did
the 4% reduction then we looked at the
individual payment types that we receive
that we receive in any given year so
estimates extensions returns and tax
notices and we looked at when those
amounts typically come in and what we
thought the adjustment would be so the
reason for doing that is obviously a
return that we receive in April is for
the prior calendar year but an estimate
that we receive in April is for the
first three months of the current year
and so it's important to understand the
different payment types and the time
period that they are reflecting because
obviously this pandemic while we all may
have known it was coming to some extent
it did kind of come very quickly and the
impact happened quickly and so we need
to understand the timing or the
underlying activity for which the
payments that we're receiving that at
what the time period is of that activity
so that we can appropriately adjust our
estimates
the other thing to note with IND is that
we did allow business individuals and
businesses that pay this tax to
essentially defer their payment that was
due in April of their return payment in
their estimate payment defer that
payment without penalties and interest
until June 15th so what that ultimately
means is that we saw April underperform
significantly but we will see May and
June over perform compared to plan as
that revenue moves from April into May
and June based on what we saw in April
we anticipate that the amount moving
from April to June will be about 90
percent 98 percent of what we
anticipated in April we are gonna see a
reduction in June it won't just be a
straight move from April to June and
that's most likely due to people's
ability to pay obviously a lot of people
even if they have interest in dividend
income are facing financial hardships
and so people's ability to pay is
slightly reduced so we've adjusted the
estimate of the move from able to June
down by 2% so flipping to the next slide
Melissa could could we look at there's
one I'm trying to find it on this this
page seems to be different than the one
we were sent two days ago the previous
page however on at one point you
mentioned on it and you may not have it
there again that you are assuming that
all the payers that didn't pay in April
and I was wondering how you whether you
had tried to look at for the largest
payers we've been talking about looking
at the largest payers to find out
whether they may have gone out of
business or something like that
well her interest and dividends whether
or not they were even for business
whether or not they've gone out of
business does not necessarily mean that
they don't have an obligation because
again when we're looking at especially
in with respect to returns is activity
that ended in December so for the most
part like I said we saw those that did
pay in April they paid very similar to
what they paid in the prior year if not
a little bit more in some cases and so
we're not anticipating a drastic change
in what in the revenue that will receive
in that has been shifted to June
it's just that 2% adjustment which is
relatively small if they do go out of
business and they declare bankruptcy
on or simply disappear do we have a
first lien in our taxes or we do have a
priority standing when businesses come
into bankruptcy and so we if there is
debt that is owed to the state
our legal team works very hard at making
sure that we are able to receive what we
can out of the bankruptcy proceedings
thank you so again you'll see if you
look at the chart in the middle of the
page the 4% reduction and that was just
kind of right sizing of the plan may
revenue looks like it will come in above
plan again that's partially due to the
shifting that was allowed and then Jun
moving forward you'll see when you look
month by month that the amounts kind of
vary a little bit you'll see that you
know July is a 20% reduction August is
16 14 10% in in October and then you'll
dip to a minus 21 percent in November
that's because we took into account the
actual filings in any given month and
the time period for which they reflect
so that's why it's not the same linear
trend like we saw with meals and rentals
it will fluctuate month month-to-month
based on the filing that's due at that
time also just for reference during the
Great Recession IND tax revenues
decreased by 16% going from fiscal year
2008 to 2009 fourteen point eight
percent from 2009 to 2010 and six point
eight percent from 2010 to 2011
again those are reference points this is
not the same as the Great Recession but
that is data that we have available and
so we will be kind of looking to that to
generally see if there's similarities
between what we're experiencing now and
thank you questions I can answer on Ind
we have three hands all of a sudden
represent of aims thank you
it seems to me that the set of the
unknown the big unknown around we can
get in June probably relates because I
don't think economically looking forward
the projection of income for taxpayers
whether its interest or dividends would
be substantially different unless they
had to sell their holdings I suppose and
and use that money for something else
but so the big thing is ability to pay
both estimates and returns and and
I know that you know this better than I
do that a significant number of our
payers taxpayers in interest and
dividends pay relatively small amounts
reflecting perhaps the income that they
rely on perhaps not but to some degree
yes and so the the difficulty that I'm
having that you're I'm having I'm sure
as well is that we just don't know until
we get those returns those payments
those estimates in mid-june correct
maybe a good comment on that or so we
did an analysis based on the number of
taxpayers in the amount of revenue even
the ability for them to move from April
to June without interest in penalties
that provision was not available to
everyone but we did an analysis
to say how many we thought would move
from April to June and that analysis
came in just about right
so April revenue produced what we
thought it would so you're a hundred
percent correct that the big question
mark for June is will taxpayers still
have the ability to make those payments
that were due in April in June and so we
have adjusted slightly for that and only
June will really tell at that point
going forward in addition to the ability
to pay we did also assume an overall
reduction in interest in dividend income
at least through December of 2020 our
analysis assumes a 25% reduction through
December of 2020 and that being due to
interest rates being low and then also
businesses their own cash needs etc
likely decreasing the amount of
distributions and dividends that they
will be paying out following December we
then modified that 25% reduction to a
set 10 percent reduction from January to
June of 21 anticipating that hopefully
at that time businesses would be
improving and there'd be more
availability to make distributions and
pay dividends but you're right it is the
combination of the underlying
distributions and dividends and interest
that generate the tax coupled with
people's ability to pay because it is a
source of income for folks and given
that the current situation results in a
reduction of income for many people they
may need to rely on this to a greater
extent that they have in the past and
that might not give them the additional
cash or liquidity to make their tax
payments
so you're actually assuming that this
recession will be over a lot quicker
stockholders receivers correct that you
know that's the assumption that we've
made in this analysis it's obviously
something that we can modify if we would
like to run different scenarios
listening to the conversation earlier
about is this gonna be a V recession is
this going to be a u-shaped recession is
this going to be a w-shaped recession
that's all tough to know at this point I
think and but as the picture becomes
clearer if it to the extent that it does
we can certainly make some modifications
but we did anticipate a fairly quick
we went a little bit deeper than the
Great Recession but we're covered up a
little faster Southworth has question
thank you I'm sorry if I missed it is
there assumption all this that by the
end of 2021 talent there will be a
vaccine because it seems like your
timeline of things bouncing back within
a year does somewhat fit the timeline of
having a vaccine by May or June of 2021
I don't we did not make an assumption
specifically about a vaccine but you are
correct that our analysis in general
assumes gradual loosening of
restrictions and expansion of the
economy starting at the beginning of
June and that may very well be dependent
on a vaccine but we didn't make an
assumption about the specific timing of
a vaccine represented Brahmi there's a
question
question is in a comment I mean the
fundamentals of the economy world are
very good before we fell off the edge
here and under the cap of a V return and
in terms of vaccine that may not happen
you know we still don't have an AIDS
vaccine yep that scenes sometimes
they're only 50 percent 60 percent
effective so you know I think economies
is going to be opening the vaccine we'll
see what happens
that'll help I guess but let's look at
the stock market yesterday and all the
analysts that I heard said it born
because of all the states that are
opening up so and the markets reacted to
it but that tells me that the farm
metals are good that and I know I'm
you're she here you have a 30% increase
in the market since the fall or
something like that it's covered by this
a box here but you know I'm kind of
green with you as to that I think the
economy is going to be opening there may
be a lag I agree with remains about
about liquidity of certain individuals
but there are a lot of individuals are
quite liquid that will continue to pay
their interest in dividends tax so I
will say that's all I just wanted to
comment thank you I was looking and I
think it's with the businesses the
analyses are fairly similar so maybe I
should put that off but the question of
how many of the people who were in the
lower quarter of paying we're going to
drop off altogether and people in the
second quarter of painting we're going
to fall down into the lower quarter next
year but on representing names just had
a question just a quick question going
back to
which said Lindsay about about your
assumptions in the in your estimate for
forecast for interest and dividends you
use percentages of that what dividends
would be down by and I didn't I didn't
get that in my notes so could you go
over that again or so we assume that
interest and dividend income will be
down by 25% through December of 2020 and
then 10% from January to June of 21 and
again the decrease year-over-year that
we saw during the Great Recession was 16
percent then to 14.8 then to 6.8 over
that three-year period we're assuming a
bigger drop but a faster return so more
of a V or use and it sound it sounds
like in the end the drop the cumulative
drop over three years would be
considerably worse than the Great
Recession I haven't calculated that out
from what you said but for the Great
Recession it was sixteen percent the
first year and then another fifteen
percent the second year and then another
seven percent the year after that right
and then it started to return correct
where we're anticipating a brief but
more dramatic drop and then a faster
return could you I don't see any more
hands but could could you just make a
note or some more Chris send Chris and
Chris can send us the updated document
that we're looking at because you had a
a 96 percent above plan increase in June
current before and you've changed it to
88 and I don't
know what else has changed so you have
actually found the only change in the
document and that very later we just
need to cross out on page five the lady
sticks about plans at the very end and
put in an a th thank you okay
communication services tax all right
moving on to communication some of those
tax CST this again has a delay in timing
I'm sure you're familiar with that
similar to M&R so the activity is a one
is a one-month delay when we looked at
CST and tried to predict out the factors
of it we was just talking about with
onion D and we sort of went back to the
Great Recession and took a look at that
with unemployment because obviously this
is a bill that that taxpayers are paying
and then the companies are omitting that
tax to the Department of Revenue
when looking back at the Great Recession
from May of 2008 to May of 2009 there
was a 20% decrease in CST this occurred
simultaneously with the high New
Hampshire unemployment rate of 6.5%
during the Great Recession we obviously
have the high unemployment rate as well
we've also had the governor had an
emergency order to say if you are unable
to pay your phone bill you could do that
at this time and your services will be
shut off so I'm going to scroll just to
the next page so you can see some of our
numbers a little bit so when looking at
how we performed we took these factors
into account what we also needed to look
at was the taxability of video
conferencing as we're using today we're
using the zoom and a lot more companies
now with having employees at home
because of this pandemic have used more
video conferencing tools which are
taxable under CST and I think we saw
occur in April so if you look down to
the second chart people was ahead of
plan by three percent which we don't
typically see with CST in April that was
from March activities so that was sort
of the kickoff of this coded 19 in the
last couple of months a situation so
when looking at that we were projecting
your May we sort of took that
information that I spoke about before
with the Great Recession and how those
numbers were affected looked at the
governor's emergency orders looked at
people's ability to pay and then sort of
balanced that with this increasing video
conferencing and potentially increase of
VoIP usage and we got to about a 10
percent reduction in May right now a
month today or about eight point eight
point seven percent down there'll be a
slight a slight increase in increase
from that ten percent to a five percent
we will see we we noted a five percent
reduction in revenue from June until
December and in January sort of resuming
things as normal from that plan would be
for fiscal year 2021 I think this this
couples would opening back up of the
state's people getting back to work and
that balancing of videoconferencing
potentially going down some but people
having the ability to pay more so
decrease like I said from June until
December down five percent and then
January through June with no loss
overall it's not a huge loss for fiscal
year 20 we anticipated a million dollar
loss and then for fiscal year 21 and an
additional million dollar loss happy to
answer any questions on CST do I think
we need to look at the years before and
after especially the
for the Great Recession because there
were massive changes going on in
communications at that point and I can't
remember maybe you do when on when our
u.s. senator led the charge to make the
internet on taxable and and the and the
legislature I think that was after the
legislature gave up the grandfathering
yeah so I just looked at the chart that
was in 2012 to 2013
okay so that one was after you looked at
I think oh no it was before
it was yes it was after the period do
you look dead okay so we have quite a
different situation now you can get very
cheap smartphones where you're paying
still by the data unit or the minute I
know a lot of really poor people that
have them
and those people have lost a lot of the
most revenue as as Phil told us and
maybe are giving them up though they
have to a lot of them are doing network
but they're in the gig economy so they
may not be able to give them up any more
than they can give up paying rent or
they'll be homeless so so it's a con
it's a complicated one but it it is a
very small revenue source for us yes
representative a brownie header
yes the interesting thing is I never
thought of paid versus built in the ten
years that we've been talking about this
revenue so so it's the obligation is
when the money comes in is when they
they get the tax not one that when it's
bad yes
they report the revenue to us based on
what they collect okay that's just a fun
I don't think we can over discuss that
so but that does play into the fact that
some people may not be able to pay their
bill so okay thank you it's the same
month right they played the 15th of the
following month
if so it is the following month yeah
it's like M&R yes anyway set up we
Laurie still has his hand up so that
wasn't discussion ah just a quick
question or a comment regarding most of
the carriers
I know Verizon has I know that that
whatever they're calling t-mobile was
print whatever is being called now have
increased the number of units available
to individuals without increasing their
charges so I don't see any change in the
communications tax taking place at all
comment done thank you by major heads
Handa yeah I didn't hear in the
discussion two-way communication then
today Skype go to some a lot more than
is happening which all in fact revenues
now I just read that I guess the DRA
said that the zone should be subject to
the tax is are we currently taxing zone
no Alyssa I can't you know our
confidentiality statue I can't comment
in particular taxpayers however I can
if
under a definition more taxing it what
exactly are we taxing in it what's the
definition I don't have that pulled up I
think I had sent you an email on that
yes you did
why can we send that to the committee
not not can't remember if there was a
good definition in there or not the
whole point in statute with the
definition to wait by the phone so it
would be considered taxable back to sort
of my previous point so that's why we
offset the loss and that's why we saw a
gain in April is because of this this
video conferencing represented major
some of those items or some of those
those companies that you are saying you
know there is an increased usage of
those and we were balancing that
increased usage with also taxpayers
inability to pay during this time which
got us to the 10% reduction in May and
then the reduction of 5% move through
people would just cease to be customers
well if they tried to sign up again
presumably they'd still owe what they
hadn't paid during the the declaration
of emergency yeah I do know I knew that
no this just anecdotally from having
children in school and people's ability
to pay and what Comcast has been doing
to try to get people to the Internet
that if people do have a pasty bill with
a balance that they can't reconnect
until that balance is paid in full so
that that's going to be interesting
going forward yes a lot of people's jobs
depend on that
they communicate okay no further
questions it looks like okay good
okay so for the we did not make an
adjustment to fiscal year 2020 plan we
felt like rat was performing for covered
very facebook lien may revenue looks to
be about 17 percent below plan or as a
reminder that's for April transactions
yes there are a few interesting pieces
confirmation that play through the real
estate transfer tax a lot before but
just as a reminder there's two important
pieces of real estate transfer tax one
is the volume you need the transactions
to occur in order to generate the tax
but then also the tax is based on the
price
so as the prices fluctuate that can
impact the tax as well and so we're
constantly kind of evaluating both
what's happening in terms of the volume
but also what's happening in terms of
the prices because if one goes down and
the other goes up it could essentially
negate each other and we could see just
normal activity so based on a survey
from the New Hampshire Association of
Realtors all but thirteen percent of the
people that responded indicated that the
coronavirus had had an impact on their
business survey indicated that 69
percent of buyers were delaying their
home searches and that 64 percent of
sellers were delaying new listings and
even taking homes off the market so
we're trying to understand and what the
data is starting to tell us is that
there was some level of transactions
that were already in process before
Kovan maybe up into the point of
actually signing the papers and that
those transactions may have still
occurred because they're kind of past
the point of no return
but then we're gonna see a reduction
when the volume decreases when people
don't list their homes or delay the
listing of their home or delay their
home search so we're anticipating a
little bit of a delayed reaction and you
can kind of see that in the numbers or
delayed impact on revenues because like
I said a number of transactions were
already in process and still continue to
occur even in April but we anticipate
those falling off also the median real
estate sales price was 9 percent in
March 9 percent ahead of March from
March a year ago according to the
Association of Realtors so your sale
prices in March of 2020 we're nine
percent higher than your sale prices in
March of 2019 so that gets to that
balance that I was talking about worse
are likely to start seeing fewer
transactions but of the transactions
that we're seeing the prices are higher
than they were a year ago and so that
kind of helps to produce that balance so
we took into account what we've seen you
see the 17 percent reduction in May
that's with most of the activity re
having occurred for this month the
reduction of 60% in June that's where
we're really feeling the full effect
because June will be for May
transactions where we're feeling like
the impact of the reduction in the
volume of transactions will really be
the largest and then you see you start
to see a steady increase back to the end
we're going out to the end of 21
although we never fully recovered to
plan numbers there are other things that
in addition to just the prices and the
volume that we're taking into
consideration obviously the fact that
mortgage rates are low will hopefully
help to preserve some level of
transaction volume and the ability with
the restrictions on the stay at home
orders being lifted the ability to fully
execute these contracts will help also
to bring the transaction numbers up but
we have to couple that with a high rate
of unemployment that we're seeing and
the fact that a number of people just
may not be looking to buy or sell a home
right now or alternatively they may be
forced into buying or selling a home
given their struggling financial
situation that could also be the same
with businesses we've all heard about a
number of businesses that have decided
to cease operations and to the extent
that they own the building that the
business has been operating in we may
see some increased transactions there
although the values or the transaction
price may be lower so these are all
things that we're kind of keeping our
eyes on while we kind of move through
the next few months and I'm happy to
answer any questions I'm representative
of Romi
you know so two weeks ago I shared a
subcommittee on let's trade beans in
Rockingham County wearing my County
responsibility hat and our registrar was
really upbeat of transactions etc and
maybe so since then but she seemed
pretty upbeat do you have data by by
county Rockingham maybe walking hams in
a bit of an aberration I mean it's still
a lot of building going on did I say in
marking ham
do you have it by county to verify
whether maybe if you'd like me to so yea
Rockingham County for was up 30.7% so
that that's transaction values that's
not necessarily counts in front of me
right now
so there was a spike for April which was
March activity we don't have for me a
it looks like in April so for March
activity in Belknap County
Darryl Capponi gesture saw slight
reduction colas saw a reduction wrapped
and saw an increase Hillsboro saw an
increase Merrimack saw a decrease in
Rockingham saw an increase Stratford was
a decrease in Sullivan was a decrease so
it's mixed across the state yeah and I
just pulled up in merry so amazed a
little bit darker than than April had a
fifteen point seven percent increase so
they were good in Stratford had a forty
two point five percent increase but all
the other counties were down Carol was
down 30 percent
Cheshire are down 51 percent COAS down
50 percent grafton down 15% Hillsboro
down 21% Merrimack down 25% Rockingham
down 26% in Sullivan down twelve point
three percent for total counties being
down 19.4% in activity okay that timing
impact kind of catching up with us of
those sales process have already kind of
worked their way through and now we're
seeing the reduction what it looked like
right it looked like there was a slight
again March but leveled off and I've
done it the dipstick
corrected itself the next month as a
question yes when you talk about
transactions sure that includes
refinancing does it or does it not that
does not so real estate transfer tax is
only when you change property or the
real estate changes hands yeah but let's
yeah but I hate you at that phrase if a
person is doing say from a trust to the
person and then back to the trust
they're paying the real estate transfer
tax because it's going from two
different people which most you know if
it's a revocable trust is that correct
you can think of it if the deed needs to
be recorded at the county then the tax
is paid so some of the transactions
could be going from the revocable trust
back to the person for the mortgage and
then back to the revocable trust the
county yep some of that's false money
it's not real indicate indication of an
actual I mean well it's an actual
transaction but it's not a sale of
property or a purchase of new property
any other questions on Rhett otherwise
we'll move to utility property tax all
right moving on utility property tax um
this one is probably the first tax that
we're going to talk that hasn't been
affected that we've seen by Cove in
nineteen at this point anyways as you
know there is a there is a lag in how
assessments are due for UPT so what
taxpayers are paying right now are
they're paying estimates based on
assessments done December 2019 that
works as they paid their assessments
they just Trude up in their January
payment for their 2019 prior to that
they're paying on their 2018 so right
now estimates that are being made for
April and June are based on their 2019
in the same with September and December
will be based on the 2019 assessments
and then in January 2021 when they get
their new assessment from December 2020
they'll true up any difference that's
there if they overpay typically they'll
put that into a credit and carry that to
offset the future estimates if they
don't have enough then they'll receive a
payment in January so looking right now
fiscal year-to-date where 3.3 percent
demo plan and and fiscally a date well
5.9 percent ahead of prior year you can
see that in April we were done 12% and
in May we anticipate being down 24% this
doesn't have anything to do with
people's ability to pay or anything to
do with Cova 19 this is really taxpayers
have some credits on file that we saw
the usage of April we know that those
credits are May is a small month let me
just note that if you look down it's
only a million dollar a month so even
though it says 24 percent it's not
$200,000 but we anticipate them
utilizing that those credits from May in
June and then July through December we
don't anticipate any reduction and again
that's based on the timing of what we
had said on when the assessed values are
done and when their estimates are paying
so since those estimates are not being
adjusted July through December because
they're paying on prior year assessments
and they already know what they're
paying for those months we don't see any
adjustment until June which is when
they're true up payment occurs based on
the December 2020
valuations and we do we do anticipate
potentially a 10% reduction in January
and then continuing that 10% reduction
through April and June on those
assessments and that's just based on
very preliminary assessment information
so you'll see for fiscal year 20 we
anticipate it being down 1.6% 1.6
million excuse me and then fiscal year
21 2.3 percent decrease taxes you can I
guess the business taxes you can tell
what credits they these businesses have
on file because there's a limited number
of them yeah this is this is a much much
smaller group of people to analyze and
look at much easier to follow those
trends and follow what they're using
versus business taxes well you're you're
talking about taxes 16,000 taxpayers
with credits versus just a handful here
with credits and do you have indications
that there will be new taxable property
constructed or does it depend on things
like us passing the the bill about net
metering
I'm Lindsay do you wanna feel that
question sure I mean we're always kind
of watching what's going on in terms of
taxable property at these estimates
don't anticipate any drastic changes in
the underlying amount of taxable
property that currently exists thank you
I think you've got it as a consideration
for variation we're always monitoring
what's going on hey Andy I don't see any
okay so the first thing we did with
business taxes was we made a slight
reduction 2.5 percent to fiscal year 20
plan just to kind of right-size it so
again even without kovat we anticipated
based on what we had seen through
February that we might come in slightly
below plans so we made that 2.5%
adjustment first next we made
adjustments based on assumptions about
the possible effects of COBIT on
business activity and that was done by
payment type very similar to what I was
talking about with IND we make specific
and different adjustments for estimates
extensions returns and tax notices based
on the underlying activity that would
occur the additional complication with
business taxes is unlike the interest in
dividends tax where almost all taxpayers
are on a calendar year business
taxpayers are on a variety of fiscal
years we've talked about this before but
approximately 90 percent follow a
calendar year but then a fiscal year
ending 630 and then a fiscal year ending
9:30 are two other very popular fiscal
year ends so we do additional analysis
to take into account the timing of
estimates and returns and extensions for
those alternate fiscal year
that don't follow the calendar year as
well so again looking at the underlying
business activity when the COBIT
pandemic would impact business activity
and then projecting when or analyzing
when that change in business activity
would be seen in revenues that resulted
in the same analysis that we've been
talking about with which is a
month-by-month variation also similar to
interest in dividends tax we did need to
adjust for the TIR or the guidance that
the department put out allowing certain
tax payers to move their return and
estimate payments from April 15th to
June 15th we saw a number of tax payers
that will make that shift we also saw
some tax payers that likely didn't
qualify to make that shift also making
minute shift and so those tax payers
will be subject to penalties and
interest but we've accounted for those
additional tax payers moving their
payments till June one bit of good news
is that when we looked at the tax payers
that paid in April they paid for the
most part they paid more than they did
in the prior year so I think
representative abirami made this point
you know calendar year 2020 our calendar
year in 2019 excuse me was a good year
this pandemic is coming off of a good
time for businesses and so that will
help kind of sustain our revenues for
some period of time and there will be a
delayed impact on when we see the impact
from Koch vid on revenues unlike M&R
where we're seeing it almost immediately
the impact on business taxes because of
how they're paid will be slightly
delayed I represented major headers hand
up but he's taking it down is that I
said no I had a question relative to the
18.7 man subject to penalties and
interest so for that eighteen point
seven million that we anticipated to see
in April that we're hoping is going to
show up in June that will be subject to
interest in penalties because they did
not qualify to make that shift in
revenue and we're not sure whether
they'll pay in June or not fingers
crossed we're hoping the ball clip and
my own okay the other question I have is
the bulk of the taxes the business taxes
that are due in 2020 the result of
businesses results at 2019 correct and
you show that you made an adjustment of
two and a half percent if all the
indications I saw was that 2019 was oh I
see is better but the thing is the
federal tax cut yes it was responsible
for that okay right so that that two and
a half percent that's a good question
and an important point so thank you for
bringing that two and a half percent
reduction to plan really is around the
amount on the surplus statement that was
anticipated for our synchronization with
the Internal Revenue Code we hadn't
anticipated or the surplus statement the
revenue estimates anticipated a pretty
significant amount of money resulting
from conformity to the Internal Revenue
Code and based on what we were seeing we
felt like that number was a little
hi so that's what that 2.5% adjustment
is okay yes thank you um so you'll see
on this slide that again
unlike meals and rentals tax but similar
to interested in given the changes in
each month are not going to follow a
linear trend because we're looking at
the specific payments that will be made
in the individual months and adjusting
based on the underlying economic
activity or business activity for that
time period so you will see fluctuations
month-to-month but we do trend a gradual
improvement in at the end of 2021
although the start of 2021 is is
definitely impacted by kovin why why do
you think that payments will be coming
in lower through what is usually a
really low period anyway in July August
and then in as well in September which
is a quarterly estimate period great and
might be the first time that we'd we'd
see people a lot of people adjusting
that wouldn't have adjusted before right
so September is that estimate payment is
going to be for July August and
September yes it's kind of hidden in
here because of the shift from April to
June showing a 10% reduction compared to
plan but if you if we were looking at
say just estimates in June for into a
more dramatic reduction because June
will be for April May and June activity
yes the peak impact from kovat at least
based on what we were anticipating and
so that September reduction is an
improvement what we anticipated
or a reduction in estimates that we're
gonna see in June but that's kind of
hard to see but we were talking earlier
people businesses tending not to react
mate until at least September when
something major happens to them I mean I
think that's going to depend on the cash
that a business has on hand I mean they
think that they don't need to adjust
their June estimate and they have the
cash on hand to make that payment then
they do so into your point their
adjustments will start to show in
September but it will be it'll it'll be
important for us to analyze what we
receive in June yes
yeah thank you we have to supplement
that a little bit represented I mean I
think we did consideration I think we
thought that in December that they would
be looking at that versus in September
that in December they would be making
their adjustments at that point when
maybe there's more funds available and
they really know what they look like
which is why the reduction isn't so
great in December
compared to $10 where it's where it's
much deeper September in June so you
expect people to look in December to be
able to feel that hey we're doing ok
after all and we owe more so we're gonna
pay it back yeah essentially that or
even to look at they may not make their
June payment and they may not make their
September payment and they may just true
that up in December when your business
situation is a little bit better and
they know where they stand with funds on
file at that point before the return is
due sort of to avoid avoid the penalty
situation
so you only charge penalty if they
haven't paid before On January of the
next year I lived in a state once for
six months they got me for income tax
and my grandmother's estate settled
halfway through that the time that I was
with them and they did interest and
penalties on me for not having done it
for an estimated tax that I hadn't even
been there for they're not like that I
know but we charge we charge interest in
penalties only if they try to show up in
January or February the next year if
they file would the return they're going
to get they'll be they'll get under
payment of estimate penalty versus if
they're paying in their quarterly
so obviously taking everything into
account we're projecting that fiscal
year 2020 little bit better than that I
think we're estimating that 9 million it
looks like we're currently down about
seven so we may be performing slightly
better than we anticipated for May but
looking at about a hundred and fifteen
million for business taxes for fiscal
year twenty and then fiscal year 21
okay we have three people with their
hands raised now representing Romney to
two questions first a tempest - 10 % of
Jim so let's make sure I understand its
you're saying that the estimates for the
first quarter going to be outweigh the
so what we're anticipating your first
for many businesses your first and
second quarter estimates so your April
and plus your April return or an
extension amount and so the minus 10% is
essentially the net of positive returns
and extensions coming out of calendar
year 19 coupled with yes a reduction in
estimates for first in second quarter of
2020 okay that makes sense to me
actually all right then
there's no question I'm just I'm big on
the you know the fact that the business
tax is a limited number companies I mean
I don't trying all we talk about all the
time and you know I mentioned
manufacturing or my sense is that a lot
of manufacturing company stayed open now
I also know that the oil industry for
instance took a big hit the last couple
of months they closed their factories
down so and I'm assuming that we make a
lot of medium-sized companies that make
components that go into things and I
would imagine we have components that go
into automobiles as an example so I
guess what I'm getting at is I mean have
you looked at it if you look at this by
industry category what they produce
you can we can't look at that because
that would get us into the granular
discussion but if you try to look at our
top companies and say well what business
is what are they really producing and
would that
affected by this magic we have beer
company a big large beer company here
that it wasn't impacted by this and that
they kept on producing but there may be
other companies that that produce for
the Defense Department that also may not
have been affected as much by this but
there are others that are producing
components of things that may have been
impacted so did you look at that at all
we did we did start to look at that and
we will continue to look at it we need
to your point we really need to do that
on a taxpayer by taxpayer basis and so
therefore we're likely to do it for the
largest taxpayers only because and we've
talked about this before the there's no
reliable way for us to know what
industry our taxpayers fall into we have
a line on our return for them to
indicate their industry code but there's
no obligation for them to fill that out
accurately and we've found issues with
that data so we do really rely on a
taxpayer by taxpayer analysis for our
largest taxpayers and we do look at what
industry do we think they operate in to
your point about manufacturing where in
the supply chain are they and what has
the impact been on that supply chain
because that might impact the timing of
the pandemic on their specific business
so we have started to do that and as we
get more returns and estimates coming in
now in June we'll be able to expand that
analysis that's basically to say here
about thank you okay represent extreme
yes thank you for taking my question
about two thousand businesses received
PPP forgivable loans which of course
aren't taxable federally I think that
the best information we have is that
they will be taxable
or be et and be PT and there's 400
million in Main Street grants coming
into effect to replace lost profits for
businesses that haven't done as well
this year as last year you know even
though they may have reduced cost by
having fewer employees they've lost more
in revenue and so on so make that up I'm
not sure whether that would be taxable
or not of those two I mean I think those
two programs together represent a lot of
G New Hampshire businesses and if
they're both taxable I you know I wonder
how that would factor in to this
estimate for fiscal year 21 BT and BT
business taxes thank you sure that's a
very good question we have not
specifically in these estimates 421
taken those two programs into the into
account although we are monitoring them
and you are correct so with the PPP
loans if that loan is forgivable it
essentially turns into a grant and while
not taxable federally that grant is
taxable at the state level same with
these Main Street business grants lows
will be taxable as revenue what will
ultimately determine any potential
revenue impact will be how businesses
spend those brands because if they have
expenses that qualify as business
deductions you could essentially have
the revenue and increase your deductions
and they'll net out to zero so it'll
really depend on what businesses do with
that money
if they take in the revenue and hold it
for a rainy day and they don't have a
deductible expense then yes that would
impact their their taxable amount so we
are continuing and have started to and
will continue to kind of put together
and keep track of all of the federal
programs that are happening and what we
think the impact
to revenues will be especially as we
move into 2021 because some things will
be direct potential direct impacts like
you mentioned with the grants others may
be things that just help spur the
economy or help under the underlying
economy and so we may not see a direct
you know that grant is taxable impact
but we may see if there's another round
of stimulus checks we may say okay maybe
when those stimulus checks come if
restaurants are open maybe we'll see
more people go out to dinner and we
should factor that in or at least
acknowledge that we may see an impact an
indirect impact from revenue from those
federal stimulus programs so we are
monitoring all of those thank you
represent major has a question
q my question has to do with this
summary of estimates for the business
taxes in April the actual was down close
to 40 percent and that's primarily new
to the deferral of the taxes in June so
I look at June of 2020 and I look at its
Dow 14 million dollars from the plan my
question is on the D FDR a revised
estimate which sells one hundred and
twenty six point six million coming in
how much of that is due to the deferred
payment I would assume that the deferred
payment added to I even if you were down
10 percent almost make that been down so
that's my question just trying to see if
I have that amount quickly so we are
assuming a shift of forty eight point
and that's a combination of 29.5 or
almost 30 million of just the the
general shift from April to June for
those taxpayers that qualified plus
eighteen point seven million from
taxpayers who didn't qualify for the
relief but it looks like they're taking
advantage of it anyway and like I said
they won't those will be subject to
so the eighteen point two will include
the penalties and interest yes
approximately I mean these are estimates
based on what we anticipate but yes
those will be subject to penalties and
interest and so the shift will help
mitigate the loss that we're
anticipating from estimate payments
because these would be q2 estimates
estimate payments like I said for April
May and June activity and for many many
businesses that's really the bottom
hopefully of what they're gonna see and
so the shift helps to mitigate that loss
that we were anticipating and part of
the penalties and interest at least is
likely not to be collectible before the
next fiscal year but the auditors at any
rate will in the kafirs send it back
right so depending on the timing of when
that revenue is received to your point
about the kafir' yes there is a window
of 60 days currently so July in August
the revenue received in July in August
we do an analysis to determine whether
the underlying business activity for
that revenue was related to new
enterprise but yes be part of our
[Music]
sorry I'm trying to get rid of that fun
on rap surnames has a question yeah
thank you
I actually have two questions I'll start
with the immediate one from that
conversation you just had 18 million
dollars or so that should have been paid
the obvious question is why it seems
like you're assuming that the answer to
the why is not significant to our
projections but I I wonder if you've had
any information from the businesses who
failed to pay these are probably pretty
big big places or whether you have a
eighteen point two million dollars in
taxes that were owed we're not paid on
time and the taxpayers are now we're
going to have to pay a penalty assuming
they're able to pay the tax itself sure
so those businesses just as a reminder
that we're due to pay in April but may
not have they in 2018 owed fifty
thousand dollars or more in tax so it's
really those in the bottom portion of
that triangle the large tax payers and I
think what's contributing to not making
that payment in April and hopefully
making the payment in June is the fact
that the federal date was extended until
July 15 and so for many of these very
large tax payers they really need the
information from their federal returns
in order to determine their state
returns and we know that in many
instances
even though it's a lot of money to New
Hampshire when you compare the amount
that some of these tax payers Oh to much
larger states like New York and
California they may do their own
analysis and say it may be worth the
penalty the small amount of penalties
and interest in New Hampshire and we're
okay with that but we need to prepare
our federal return first and deal with
our larger states before dealing with
you Hampshire so I do think it's the
impact of the federal return not being
due until July 15th that's a good answer
I like that answer yeah doesn't have it
doesn't have repercussions I think so my
my I guess larger question is I think
before seeing your your estimates I I
had assumed I think others that assume
that we may be seem to be seeing a high
and low we talked a little bit about
that in the interest and dividends
discussion and I guess my question to
you is have you sort of have you served
ballparks on on best case worst case
you've given us a single number here and
maybe we're going to want to move into
us a best case worst case I think going
into this exercise our assumption was
that we would do that and I'm wondering
if you've done it and can help us think
about best case worst case sure we have
not done that analysis yet and that's
really I think based on the fact that
June is going to hopefully tell us a lot
of information and will allow us the
better formulate ranges of highs and
lows as I mentioned when we started this
presentation we've had to make a number
of assumptions just to get to these
numbers and I think it would have just
been a whole other level of assumptions
to get to highs and lows without that
data coming out of June and so I think
like I said we can take
June data take what we've done here and
then better formulate ranges but we were
trying to just get some some numbers out
here and keeping our assumptions
although they were significant to a
minimum if possible so my hope I'm July
will be better able to do ranges for 21
yeah I understand that we've got the
same problem
mm-hmm we're gonna have better numbers
in two weeks three weeks in three weeks
we'll have better numbers that will shed
a lot of light on this I think it'll be
more more like a month and so now we've
madam chair will we be receiving a copy
of this slideshow presentation thank you
the slideshow presentation you have a
copy of the slideshow presentation with
the one it came from Chris Shea twice I
didn't see it the first time the second
time was Monday and there is one
exception on it which is the a changed
on page five for interest and dividends
tax thank you which went from ninety six
percent to eighty eight percent yeah
we've got that already
[Music]
Southworth has his hand up and now
there's another thank you for taking my
question
I'm sorry if I missed it did you would
all consider what might happen if
unemployment is extended especially the
extra $600 for that group of people we
did not consider that specifically here
thank you we have senator bra me what I
represent astronomers common about the
PPE if I guess the role was 75% I say if
they use 75% to keep people on the
payroll that the grant will happen I
guess that's one of the requirements
anyway which to me dat and as we
discussed that's taxable income
standpoint or from a being key
standpoint is that is that correct yes
that's correct so do we know maybe one
thing we can do and I would imagine most
companies that get it will indeed keep
their employees on you know even if you
say ninety percent that do we if we can
find out how much PP may have done us
not much PPP was allocated to New
Hampshire companies and we can kind of
work backwards to see you know that
impacts now I know we have
multinationals that may be harder to do
but I don't think they were eligible did
the larger I think publicly traded
companies weren't involved today they
weren't supposed to be so we can take
that information and do some rough
calculations and kind of balance that
against the unemployment numbers cuz
again it's a mitigating factor against
the drop that we're likely to see due to
unemployment yes and we've got to look
at the unemployment vs. how many jobs
there were before mm-hmm to deal with
that as well it's it gets pretty
complicated if you try to go down into
sectors unfortunately because they use
different sectors to to report the
unemployment than they do the employment
okay we're out of questions on that okay
so just the last slide is very similar
to the slides at the beginning
it's really just a summary so this slide
here just summaries summarizes by the
tags type actual for April what we
anticipate for May with just a few days
left here and then what we anticipate
for again you'll see at the very end
overall we're anticipating one hundred
and thirty five point eight million
dollar reduction compared to plan in
revenue for April to June which is
approximately twenty three percent and
then the next slide is just a high-level
summary and this is exactly what's on
the first page of fiscal year twenty and
fiscal year twenty one so you're looking
this seems to be where the governor's
conviction that we will have more than a
six percent decline
comes from correct so this is very close
to a six percent decline I will note
that the triggers for the business tax
rates are all revenue all general and
education trust fund revenue so not DRA
revenues exactly other than what's in
here and also it is the revenue based on
the comprehensive annual financial
report or the kafir' that is issued in
December and if snapper takes into
account some of those accounting
adjustments or accrual adjustments and
so we will be watching that very
carefully so I there is a chance based
on projections at this point that what
we see on a cash basis at the end of
June well will or will not trigger that
the business tax rate changes but it's
ultimately the Khafre number that takes
into a CREP into account those
accounting adjustments that is the the
true trigger so we won't know until the
half and it occurs to me that the large
largest businesses that are waiting to
file and pay until they have finished
their July 15 federal returns and then
broken it
down to the states they may be paying us
in August right so that is within the
60-day window that we look at for the
year before it will for the cat fur we
will not know about that from cash in
hand at the end of June correct which is
right which is why depending on what
cash looks like at the end of June the
answer could be different in December
when we make the final determination
about the rates right perhaps we could
try and estimate that we are going to
ask all of the agencies every two months
if they've got any changes in their
estimates for for the business and
interest and dividends taxes it looks
like we need to ask about if there are
any changes in the estimates they go
back to 2020 also sure great againi I
don't see any further questions thank
we are going to it's 20 past 12:00 so we
have 40 minutes for lunch at one o'clock
we should all be back and connected so
that that we can listen to the people
from the chambers for for half an hour
and then we'll start in on all of the
other taxes and revenues representative
owl me if I may interject there are two
hands up but yes finish first thank you
I would just suggest if it's if people
are comfortable with it they may just
want to remain connected so they don't
have to go through and find the the link
to reconnect later I will end the
recording but they they're free
means to remain connected I'm not going
to close the meeting right and I see
that representative Lang has joined us
absolutely
Thank You chip mr. chairman I just want
to tell I did join in way back when when
you were talking about rooms and meals
tax and I was listening to the
conversation I will be missing the
afternoon session only because I have
the reopening taskforce meeting
and I don't think that there should be a
problem signing back on but if you want
to just leave it running there's no
problem with that either you can just
minimize it like you would any other
window if you're on a PC you go to you
take the cursor up to the top and it
gives you X it full screen are you on a
PC or a Mac PC yes so you go up to the
top of the screen with the cursor and
the top bar shows up it goes away again
unless you use that's okay are you
moving the cursor to it yeah yeah talk
yep don't worry don't worry also about
you okay the other thing people might
want to do is just stop your video and
and make sure you're muted yep very good
okay thank I think that's it